excuse me
not a good time to do that is it et's
taking a look at the most memorable
moments inside the 2020 cma awards
[Music]
morgan wallin took home new artist of
the year his first
cma award well i did not expect to get
this
et's rachel smith talked to wallen after
his win and he reflected on the
controversies surrounding his cancelled
snl appearance
last month yeah i mean i think i just
gotta be aware that most of my actions
will
you know if especially if i'm in a
public situation it's gonna be brought
to light
and before all that kind of happened i
didn't i didn't i don't think i really
truly understand the
the reach that i have country music's
biggest night
turned into date night on the red carpet
carrie underwood and her hubby mike
fisher
miranda lambert and her husband brendan
mclaughlin
and reba mcintyre making her red carpet
debut with boyfriend of eight months
rex lynn we're gonna have a big time
we'll have lots of fun
country fans got a crossover moment with
pop star justin bieber
making his cma awards debut
[Music]
[Applause]
jb joined dan and shea at the hollywood
bowl in los angeles performing their
song
ten thousand hours
[Music]
but there were more than a few
performances fans didn't get to see
and it's because of the coronavirus
pandemic
before the night got started lady a
announced they would not be able to
perform
in a social media post the band wrote
sadly one of our immediate family
members has just tested positive for
covet 19 this week
so far the three of us continue to test
negative and out of caution and love for
everyone involved with the cmas
we've decided to stay home from the
awards tonight
but lady a member charles kelly had
already pre-taped a performance with
carly pierce days before
and kelly had actually stepped in to
replace lee bryce
who revealed on sunday that he had
tested positive for covid19
it is surreal i don't know how to
explain it carly gave e.t the update
backstage after she won musical event of
the year
for her song with lee called i hope
you're happy now
lee tested positive for covid then
charles kelly who was going to step in
for you
uh as or charles kelly was going to step
in for lee
he did because you guys pre-recorded
that performance correct
we did and you know it's just been it's
been an intense 10 days i'll tell you
um right before all of that happened i
had a an accident i i didn't tell you
when i talked to you but i
i fell on halloween and
had a bunch of stitches in my mouth
knocked my two front teeth out was like
completely mangled so the fact that i'm
like
standing here being able to talk and
like do all this and then the lee and
then the charles it's just been like
such an intense 10 days so this like
makes it all worth it and like i was
kind of embarrassed to be here with my
face
and so it's just um it's awesome now are
charles and lee both doing okay
they are i mean i've spoke to both um
charles and i actually just
texted a little bit i was just like you
killed it they're both doing good i
facetime with lee today
everybody's good they're just you know
bummed that they can't be here
then at the 11th hour rascal flatts
revealed they were dropping out
the band posted this message to social
media after the ceremony had already
begun
hey y'all we wanted to let you guys know
that we have received a positive covet
test within the band
it is still unclear which of the group's
three members had tested positive
and lastly fiddler janae fleener
announced before the show that she had
tested positive for covid19
janae took to social media to express
her disappointment
at having to cancel her performance she
wrote i am thankfully feeling just fine
just bummed of course following the high
profile dropouts
the country music association released a
new statement about their coven 19
precautions
which had already included multiple
testing for all guests
spaced out tables and requiring masks be
worn when attendees leave their assigned
seats
their statement read in part quote we
are following all protocols that have
been put in place by the cdc
as well as the creative unions to ensure
we provide the safest environment
possible
the night's biggest honor went to eric
church the desperate man singer one
entertainer of the year
well it's going to be ground viking and
a tease
e.t chatted with co-hosts reba mcintyre
and darius rucker leading up to the big
night
what can we look forward to with this
award show
where is it going to be how is it going
to happen how are y'all pulling it off
during the midst of a pandemic
well it's going to be in a different
venue it's going to be at the uh
music national music center national
music city center
music city center so it's going to be
different and the way that the people
that we're going to be talking to
and the seats will be the presenters the
performers
the nominees and we're going to have a
great time
and we're going to just exude our
personality tell you the truth we're
flying by the seat of our pants and we
can't wait to get up there and start the
[Music]
show